yeah i wonder
i think there's a bbc documentary on uh
i think it's called something like
charisma
hitler's charisma or something like that
just quite
i mean that one focused more about the
power of the speeches
but i wonder if most of the success or
the
rise of hitler and the third reich had
to do with the
charisma of hitler when he's alone in a
room with somebody with the generals
just one-on-one like i wonder i wonder
if that's the essential element
of just being able to just look into a
person's eyes
like flatter them or whatever is needed
right to earn their trust
and then convince them of anything you
want right
yeah i mean you're right because that's
that's the one piece of history we don't
have i don't know
we don't know we do know that the kid
crushed
i mean he was a headliner he got up
there and his phone
yeah there's certain elements about
nationalism and pride that are really
powerful like
a lot of us uh humans i think
long for that for the feeling of
belonging and when some charismatic
leader
makes us feel like we belong to a group
the uh the amount of evil we can do to
other humans because of that
especially nobody wants to look in
nobody wants to do the work to be better
or look at where they messed up why does
it always have to be the jews that are
there
you know it's like get over it guys
i mean it's like they killed jesus you
get over it yeah okay it's a long time
ago i mean move on
i'm jewish i understand because we do
run the central banks and uh and the
weather
and the weather yeah don't forget about
the weather that's a big one
that's a funny one that people created
like who gives what is the weather like
what's the importance of the weather all
right the jews made it rain outside good
you gotta [ __ ] you know they made snow
okay you get a day off thank the jews
yeah it's like yeah there's certain
conspiracies that make me like flat
earth
like what what's the motive like what
who's what's the motivation
for lying that the earth is round like
what's the conspiracy yeah what does
anyone get out of it
yeah what is exactly the pro the profit
what's the what's the strategy
you